[Music]
this week we've got
cheese challenge erase your ex and fine
print contest
is the cheese challenge throwing cheese
at your babies yeah
oh i hate that wait what yeah pretty
people
throwing cheese at their baby sticks on
the baby's head
let me show you i hate it here we go
oh the babies even know why it's
happening
oh he was already crying and he stopped
crying he stopped crying
i want the cheese so
jesus we're getting so dumb people are
so [ __ ]
dumb this is baby pranks this is so
stupid
i just think they're doing nothing this
is so stupid they don't have the fine
motor skills to defend themselves
they're so stupid this is like making
fun of someone with a disability exactly
that's literally what it is like i'm
stupid as [ __ ] but i don't even get this
this is stupid like i i do some crazy
[ __ ]
i don't even get it's like we're taking
disabled people out of their wheelchairs
[Laughter]
and then you cut to another guy doing it
it's like okay i'm laughing at how
stupid it is it is they're
the parents well you gotta admit though
it is kind of cute i'm laughing at the
parents
like how dumb are you you think this is
i want to get the parents and get the
big block of cheese and then do that to
them yeah straight garment cheese
it's like uh now having a kid i can see
the developmental stages
so if you're throwing cheese at a
four-year-old like i'm like okay
that might be funny there's just plops
there were some videos of older kids but
these kids
like they bare they don't even know left
from right
they barely just learned okay if i
inhale i get oxygen in
like this is how to breathe and now you
just stop their breathing
and they can't even track like their
tracking is off right now
because like you could throw something
at them and they're like wait what
where did that go yeah it's so slow so
it is like making fun of disabled people
it really is
when i was a parent a young parent you
did the honorable thing you gave your
kid a lemon
yes that's pretty good that's it it's
harmless
it's harmless to do that [ __ ] where
they're like that sour face
and then their kid learns they're like
okay then the next time i get my kid
living it was like nah fam i remember
last time you did that yeah yeah
i think this one is different because
it's a projectile yeah like you're
chucking something at them
and it's like shocking them it's like
you like makes the sound when it smacks
on their face
it's covering their nose the biggest
part for me is it's covering their nose
and they just learn how to breathe
it's confusing i get the love she ended
up
tweeting out she's like i love a prank
as much as anybody but i cannot get
myself to throw cheese at my adorable
unsuspecting baby who has all the hope
and trust in the world
yep that's exactly what it is i think as
the baby when the baby puts you in a
home
they should play that video here you go
enjoy shady pines
then they should throw the [ __ ]
cheese at them
now that would be great these kids
throwing cheese at their parents
that are in wheelchairs they take them
out of the wheelchair throw them on the
ground and then throw cheese
they pull they pulled out that clear
tube thing out of their nose
they pull that clear thing and then
smack on their face
50 years later yeah so they could like
not breathe his teeth
dude in knowing knowing the vegan
community online they're pro people
probably pissed at this they're using
cheese at all
like should have used [ __ ] daiya or
whatever it's not even a real cheese
no but yeah but exactly it's it's the
shitty yeah yeah american cheese is real
cheese that's real cheese too made in
america yeah it says made with real milk
velveeta is not real cheese yeah
that's powder i just heard that
velveeta is like scientifically prepared
or whatever yeah
it's like spam it's made out of velvet
it's like the nacho cheese cheese
it's like powder i love it yeah i love
it too
you could have said it's the nacho
cheese not the nacho cheese cheese
you had to double up on it up
growing up that was the what's up [ __ ]
all right anyway
so they are saying that this doesn't
qualify
as child abuse or whatever it doesn't
it's just stupid
it's just stupid yeah because it's not
technically harming the kid
the kids are just more confused than
anything they're just [ __ ]
i got a lot of stuff going on right now
it's like the kids it's like the kids
learning how to walk and the parent
keeps like kicking their leg like
yeah i mean it's not really abused but
once they learn how to walk then when
you kick like dennis funny
yeah that's for me like if that's what
i'm saying like once the kid knows how
to breathe
and they kind of understand then you
start throwing the cheese i think it's
funny but
they can like whack it out yeah if they
can do that
then maybe then it's a game kids are
just like
it's sad and it just stays there what is
happening
what are you i thought you loved me the
kids just looked so disappointed like
really you're my you're my mom you can
already put
them in like little pumpkin outfits and
[ __ ] yeah like it's
like they can already look pretty silly
because of you yeah
you don't have to also throw cheese at
their face right what is
what is what are everyone loves it
everyone thinks no i mean no no most
people think it's
most people think it's really dumb okay
but there's a ton of people that are
participating
and i rarely comment negative [ __ ]
um and i'm always like this is so
[ __ ] dumb you guys need to be more
creative i [ __ ] i hate it
i just hate when people take advantage
of like uh people that can't
like protect like yeah yeah what's your
animals and
what's your take on baby costumes though
because honestly like i
could actually see myself dressing up
like my baby
as like a trash bag or something because
it's really fun there's nothing wrong
with that
that's cute yeah what's wrong with that
there's nothing wrong okay cool i'm just
checking yeah
yeah or something you know making them
like look like a butt or something
like like humiliating them yeah because
they don't know what's going on i just
find that too
i think that's cute i'm like you
remember hey look at you hey
for your first hallway you were a
[ __ ] butt what do you think of that
like later in life you get to show them
that [ __ ] i can't wait till you were
dead oh i can't wait to either
yeah nikki's not going to let that shift
lie she will she's super
laughing no cause she we put the cats in
costumes every christmas
that's awesome we basically laugh until
we cry because they
they like wear like little elf [ __ ]
things with a beard
like a little santa hat and they're just
like
[ __ ] pissed about it but we love that
[ __ ] that's cool because you think it's
hilarious there's some people that are
like legit like
i love the way my pets look in this and
it's not funny that's true
that's sad and like putting rainbow
people
rain boots on a dog and [ __ ] a part of
me understands that i would never do it
but i do get it because
some people are just germaphobes and
they're like this dog is walking
barefoot in
[ __ ] and then now they're coming
directly into my house the one that bark
hasn't picked up
but i picked all them up i get it it's
just such a pain in the ass i'm like you
gotta be a weird person to do this
regularly we have a friend that does it
yeah
but i get it oh really what about dogs
on high heels
that's [ __ ] cute or the dogs with the
pantyhose there's dogs in high heels
no there's not i'm just back i was like
wait dogs i've never seen because i knew
about the pantyhose one
those are [ __ ] funny that's pretty
funny what's the pantyhose one
you just put them in pantyhose and they
like they look kind of seductive a
little bit
because their leg is like which is the
way she did it like i see the one where
they draw the eyebrows that one's
hilarious
the closest thing i think i did to the
cheese thing and i felt bad was uh we
were
at taika's cousin's birthday at one of
those like trampoline park places yeah
sky high scott like
is it called sky high sky high sky zone
guys all this guy's all right
yeah so it's one of those things and
then taika was like waddling on a
trampoline and then i'm like oh this
would be so awesome i'm just gonna run
jump and tyke is gonna get launched into
the air did that
i didn't finish my story oh so i went
there and i was gonna do that but the
minute my
foot touched the trampoline his feet
already came out
from under the landing he kind of like
belly flopped on his back and i'm like
they started crying i was like oh no so
i had to run over there i picked him up
and i already felt that
he was crying from that you were gonna
launch from 40 feet in the air
so afterwards when he was crying i held
on to him i'm like pressing the
trampoline trying to figure out like
what's going on
i'm like how come it didn't turn out the
way i imagined and i go touch the other
trampoline and it's because the baby
trampoline section
to allow them to walk it's way more taut
versus the other one it goes it really
goes like this
so the other one this one is already
like like really taut so the minute i
step on it it really affects him already
but if he was on the other one i could
have jumped and he would have been
launched forward if you're in there and
i could have caught him dude you should
put velcro on a wall and put velcro on
don't kill him
let me sit don't give him my dude don't
give them ideas or even throw them
against the couch because the couch is
kind of fuzzy yeah dude
let me think taika and move on to the
next story okay
too late i already have ideas in my mind
damn all right so
this new website called edit my x has
launched it's an
online service where you upload a photo
and then
their image editing experts will erase
your ex from the photo this is black
mirror for 11.90
11.90 oh my god i can't talk oh what
that's fantastic he just looks like a
weirdo
at the bottom yeah this brings up a
funny story a friend of mine went to
paris with his girl that's not his ex
and every picture they took together at
every iconic thing
at paris europe they went like for three
weeks he took one picture with her
and one by himself in case they broke up
what a romantic guy
broke up she was like what are you doing
he's like ah you know it's just i just
want to see what i would look like
along the way that is crazy because this
didn't exist yet
so now he could just do this kind of
pricey
twelve dollars a photo did he dump her
he did so he was already
[ __ ] he knew he was already
questioning the relationship
pre-meditated dude
because that's just wild i would never
do that because people now usually you
have to delete
delete the pictures of you and your ex
and people are like oh snap what's up
with the boy and on your gram no more
now you just re-upload those yeah you
know what crazy i actually did that too
did you what did you do similar to that
you already knew
well yeah i didn't want to be with this
dude anymore and so whenever we would go
to places that it was like
no special like shakies
go shaking it's at 1pm
[Laughter]
yeah i got a mojo potato photo [ __ ]
let's do it
no yeah so like um like at disneyland
for example
it would be new years it's a special
occasion i'd have isaac with me and i'd
just make them like oh take a photo of
me and isaac
i see you know you don't need to be in
this photo
this is a family photo dude imagine
being a franchise owner of a shakies and
you're watching this video and you're
like
like they just said shakings that it
made everyone laugh
that's a terrible feeling they said it
again and they laughed harder the second
time
[ __ ] you just say shakies and it gets a
laugh that's unbelievable
that's so terrible for our brand what
have they done to that
company man holy [ __ ] i love shaking i
love do you really
yeah the mojos tell me a place that
makes better mojo what the [ __ ] is a
mojo
mojo potato it's like the sliced
potatoes but it's like seasoned
i thought it's just i thought it's a
pizza place they do pizza and fried
chicken oh
pizza fried chicken mojo potato and a
salad bar
i've never gone i've never gone i've
never been that poor we should
what is it like nine dollars all you can
it's not that poor is it
dude
race by us while we were eating yeah
remember and they kept they and they
they picked him up and put him on the
fryer we went there sorry
he he got out we went to that sheep i
remember where we went
do you remember that roach i remember
the roach i remember going to shakies
for lunch we were eating in a [ __ ]
roach
yeah and then the mexicans started
singing cucaracha
no for real they were they really were
they were like
and then they're laughing about it
shakey's is the hometown buffet of pizza
places
yeah there it is it's the lowest on the
very
pizza cece's is worse than shakies i've
never been there cece's is like
paper thin i never heard of she's like
yeah it's like it's in the south and um
yeah i've seen i drove like 5.99 for the
buffet the pizza is like
paper that's shakies too 5.99 for the
buffet man
i think so when i hear those prices i go
um love the deals i love the deals yeah
but you've never been a shakies yeah i
know so you don't love the deals
we'll take you i can get a little
caesar's pizza for cheaper
that's been 5.99 bro but you don't just
have to eat it within two minutes or the
salad
it's not all you can eat i fried chicken
fried chicken yeah yeah
that i eat with ketchup on it because
it's like this cracker it's weird
jesus souls thanks jill make me want to
go
i'm uh yeah i should start your food
channel yeah wow
all right here we go on our last story
so this woman read the fine print on her
insurance
policy and found out that there was a
secret contest
where she won ten thousand dollars oh my
god that would be you
me yeah you do what you were the one
that found
uh or maybe you don't but you were the
one that found out that and christina is
like
so when they announced their pregnancy
uh they had like
us do scratchers and she was like we
were all so stupid we're like
okay we're scratching and really trying
to win some money she was the only one
that read it first and then she like
told everyone that no because i love for
scratchers i love scratching everything
and then i figure out like what i want
and i was like wait we're having a baby
oh [ __ ] they're having a baby okay but
yeah no fine print and like policies and
[ __ ] that i click accept every time i
don't i don't know oh there's
no idea do you guys see that document in
terms of conditions no
oh my god it was on netflix it's about
like what stuff is in the terms and
conditions like yeah we basically give
away
everything all the information right i
mean if we are handing it to facebook
and yeah
everybody you know see the other side
then i won't be able to use these things
listen my thing is take everything you
want if technology is going to take over
the world
at least make it convenient for me in
the process yeah so like all the ads are
like i was thinking about this and then
i saw it on instagram
that's really convenient like it's kind
of scary but at the same time i'm like
oh snap i didn't know i could buy this i
think the irony of it
are the people that are extremely
private where they don't want to give
their information
but what they don't know is when you
accept it you're literally giving all
you're already saying i'm not going to
be a private person take off
it doesn't it's like the batman movie
like remember when he found the
uh the joker using cell phone technology
yeah like if you're the only one who
doesn't do it it doesn't matter
everybody else around you is already
doing it yeah so
unless you live like in rural montana in
like a cage and
you know if you cage i mean not a cage
or like a like a compound or something
if you interact with society on a
day-to-day basis you're screwed yeah so
if i don't use a cell phone but
everybody else does here
then they can still listen to me so dude
it's so funny my brother um
my brother's in the air force and he his
wife
um is like i want to be off the grid
like i don't have a cell phone i'm not
doing this [ __ ] and i'm like your
husband's in the air force
you're like you are as a human being
registered in the government in like 20
different ways
you married the group grip he literally
is the grit they are the ones that
created the grid you're not
part of the grid you're part of the gr
the attack force for the group
what the [ __ ] are you talking about and
they also don't uh use microwaves
because they think it [ __ ] with you
somewhere
listen i go to clear you guys have clear
when you fly no i want to
oh you they got to scan your eyes and
fingerprints of course
as long as i can skip the line yeah i
think i'm going to do as long as i i got
tsa pre-check
and clear i'm going to do really i fly
every week
really where you go i wanna i do stand
up comedy on tour oh that's tight
every week for the most part i fly so
with clear it takes literally
five minutes clear is better than tsa
because i never had problems
tsa precheck is great yeah uh but clear
like you
you skip the line like they literally
once they leave so there's no line and
clear
no line oh they take you right to the
front so like like at holidays you guys
know in la on like thanksgiving the
lines like
it's not half long they will literally
walk you past everyone in line oh that's
the best feeling because you're
literally
like oh that's so tight ass got on i
smoke a pipe
i got a monocle on look at like sherlock
holmes just to walk through you peasants
even when
you should walk up to people to fly on
southwest
you should walk up to people and [ __ ]
tip their luggage over
it's the best and it's not even in every
airport they're like 20 25 airports
have you heard of the american airlines
uh there's a specific tunnel in american
airlines at lax
yeah i think it's a membership but uh
you go
directly in there and it's like a lounge
and then you go straight to the tarmac
yep
and so it's literally like five minutes
from going into the
onto the plane but i don't know how to
get the membership me neither i've
looked at it i've seen people
flying on plane fighting on planes with
famous people yeah and they get off the
plane first they go to like an escalade
on the tarmac
yeah and they just go straight to like
out of lax that's so
tight that's the fastest thing ever what
i love about this though is that you're
you're skip you're skipping the line
walking in front of everyone be like hmm
[ __ ] see you later
and then you get into coach yeah yeah
yeah
i [ __ ] love it at least i didn't wait
in line how are you gonna sit next to
everybody
like hey i know i was a dick before
sorry yeah
so look at the back of the plane yeah
exactly exactly
damn it's funny but yeah so this is
donella she is a teacher
and so she says that she even square
mouth
it's a travel insurance company oh yeah
cause i
i recognized it too i was like oh yeah i
bought something so wait how did you win
this
she read the fine print fine print like
the child only person that read the fine
print so what was that
what did she read was there like some
some like loop or something
no so they actually put in a contest
there was this section titled
pays to read and it was sandwiched
between legal terms
on page 7 of nearly 4 000 words
wow holy [ __ ] that's where they
said like hey you know we're running
this contest to make sure people
like they actually read the policies
that's really cool yeah so then they
that just means she was the only one
that was constipated that day
she needed a lot of reading material and
she was like [ __ ] she reads
everything like everything she printed
out her insurance policy sat down and
started reading it
yeah and then so she also reads like
that hipaa document that they give you
at the doctor's office
she reads everything she's she's one of
those people who
one of those old ladies who watches
people's court and she's like it just
gets my heart racing
yeah so this contest they were planning
on having it run for a whole year
but it was over 23 hours into
because of her because she she she
probably was the only one her
and gina's mom were the only people
would ever want that she just beat my
mom by like five minutes
yeah and so um square mouth they ended
up
they were planning on donating the ten
thousand dollars to
a charity because no one was submitting
no like if no one
won it for a whole year and then so um
so they ended up donating or they they
gave her the grand prize money and then
they donated an additional five thousand
dollars to each of the two
high schools where she works to improve
their media centers and ten thousand
dollars to
children's literacy charity that's
called reading is fundamental
so they donated all this money after
this so this great publicity for them
yeah i love it that was really cool
[Music]
you